Caught in the net covered
arms of the pond.
The ducks are easy prey
and are picked off by the
dozen. But as time moves
on, the British
aristocrats turn to ways
to kill even bigger
numbers of fowl on their
ponds.
Enter the Punt gun, a
boat mounted anti duck
super weapon.
Punt guns were massive
guns.
I mean, if you look at
an old picture of
somebody holding one of
these things, it looks
like it shouldn't even
exist.
It had to be mounted to a
special boat called a
punt. And that's how the
gun got its name.
Up to 14ft long.
A punt gun can turn a
flock of eider ducks into
entrees before you can
say bang.
When you fire the punt
gun, you are sending a
spray of shot into the
air and you could take
down dozens, maybe even
up to 100 birds in a
single shot.